so this is new this is different today
putting worth it we're just going to one
restaurant let me do my best Steven
impression today on work day not holding
my tail we're gonna go to what it's
supposed to be the best restaurant in
Los Angeles called Providence always the
restaurant that comes up or a motion
sensored restaurant in LA best
restaurant in LA this is that an
opportunity where we can try out an
entire tasting menu that we're doing
well how many courses it is today we're
gonna be having seven it varies by the
menu that you get it is number one on
Jonathan Gold's 101 best restaurants in
LA he's pretty much the Yoda of
restaurant criticism he's one of pull to
a surprise I think is the only God now I
know why you say so much dumb because
when you're driving a car and trying to
do this at the same time now you get it
also when you're looking to the rich
people here who make direct contact with
Adam I thought it was obvious for those
with having eyes with that in the
holiday
[Music]
my name is Magnus Marcy we're here at
Providence restaurant in Hollywood and
you guys are gonna be eating in seasonal
menu that we have today Providence is a
fine dining modern American seafood
restaurant our goal always is to exceed
people's expectations for food for
service we want people that come in here
and leave thinking that it was better
than what they thought it would be one
of my very first expressions yeah and
honestly like it's kind of daunting
you're dropping a lot of money and you
want to enjoy it as much as you enjoy it
but my advice is relaxed if you come in
here and you feel like nervous and have
butterflies in your stomach it should be
about anticipation I shouldn't be like I
hope I don't fart at the table or use
the wrong fork do you want to crack
jokes with us and have a good time then
that's what we want to do for you so you
know I think a great way to start a meal
is maybe show up a little bit before
your reservation and spend some time
with Kim at the bar and try one of his
cocktails today you're going to try our
new Bloody Mary when you order Easter's
at the restaurant best choices in town
you get cocktail sauce this is the
kitchens version as a byproduct we get
almost like a concentrate for a Bloody
Mary
we roast corn we infuse it in tequila I
separate the corn dehydrate it grind it
up like Rim the glass with this roasted
corn it's as if their cooking is in my
drinks which is a great sort of harmony
between the bar and the restaurant
cheers Cheers
[Music]
mmm do you like Bloody Marys I like new
experiences it's like a spicy soup you
love spicy soup I've heard a lot about
this restaurant and I'm nervous about it
I think that's a good feeling though
it's like going on an awesome roller
coaster drip drip drip drip up to the
top this is the introduction this is the
prelude the animated short before the
Pixar movie this is when the shuttle is
standing on the launch pad and there's
just all that condensation coming off
with is that stuff it's the foreplay
okay we're ready to do this so first you
guys are gonna have the rocky sweet
melon with Gaeta
so the melon it's compressed in a
sous-vide machine with lemon verbena
sort of changes the texture and allows
the flavor to penetrate the melon the
gooey duck are you know at the peak of
their season I mean we always try to
have whatever it is that we're starting
with be a reflection of the season
chilled melon soup with it that dish is
really just about summer ready ready are
you ready no ears this is a whole
different flavor world
see this is what I'm scared we're on
another like you jump on the court with
LeBron James you don't know what to say
or do it's a whole different sport when
he's playing it I can honestly say that
I've never eaten anything that looked
like this ever
[Music]
life as a first bite to a meal it's like
you're walking towards a circus you hear
that elephant knees whatever an elephant
saundra yeah I know I was getting into
but I didn't quite know until I got that
first sensory hit a second course you're
going to have the sashimi of Thai
snapper with brie and water kimchi you
know what's best I think about Thai
snapper is the texture in your mouth and
then number two they're very clean
oceanic flavors white daikon red daikon
green onion jalapeno pear and apple and
all of those ingredients are mented
together so then the last thing the
juice that the radishes were pickled in
and we do everything we can to preserve
egg reclaimer and the texture of all of
the raw anything--this is what I always
wanted my mouth that's pretty good
people who get weirded out by sashimi
are like you it's raw fish boy dish
washed up on the shore fresh cats eating
fish skeletons out of dumpsters
I doesn't look like a fish skeleton in a
dumpster that looks like a garden that
group fish there was a beautiful petal
or fish we go back to the gardening cuz
I want to say sure no true or work that
everything's filthy number one and
number two and you come up with that
negative yeah you're gonna have the
abalone with charred avocado the variety
there uses almost meaty and bacony
abalone are raised then we massage each
one of them by hand which I know it
sounds silly but it's true we roast
abalone in a combination of olive oil
and butter it's set atop a grilled slice
of avocado and a puree of charred
avocado we put a crumb that is coconut
ground tortilla and dried banana oven
dried bananas the beginning of this I
thought my taste buds were playing
basketball LeBron James turns out my
taste buds have entered a ballroom or
part of this just massive dance you
can't name it famous dancer you had
basketball LeBron James but you said
ballroom we just had fancy dance so
abalone name the play of a punch you
expect the abalone name which is
massaged by hand by the way I'm not even
massaged by ham so many things happening
that you can't pinpoint one thing yep
and I think that is the best part right
when you watch a movie and you're like
that was a great movie what is your
favorite part yeah it's like no the
whole thing I mean there was a part
where somebody got blown up and it was
awesome that's the abalone here
[Applause]
next we're gonna have a Santa Barbara
spot prawn spot prawns are really only
great when you cook them from line you
do a lot of different things with it
heads of the prawn we turn to that chip
others we turn into sauce still others
we put in a spice mill with sea salt so
that when we season a prawn were
actually seasoning it with a salt that's
flavored with rum I don't know if I've
ever had a better prawn than Santa
Barbara's this is like a childhood snack
for me that has been elevated a billion
times yeah
oh that's really good
I can't believe how good that is I mean
I can believe how good this is balanced
but a little bit on edge
you know like I'm pleasantly surprised
with how much I'm enjoying this I feel
like you really grown into the occasion
California white seabass wrapped in
lardo and foyer brick which is a
Tunisian pastry once we roasted it on
all sides then we can slice it and show
it the beautiful rosy center of the fish
the lardo just melts that leaves behind
all of that deliciousness there's a
whole bunch of herbs a lot of which we
grow up stairs just practicality we pick
what we need for the day we leave the
rest of the plant and keep growing
dwelle farm they have this corn they
test the sugar levels oftentimes that
sugar content will be as high as stone
fruit which is really remarkable and so
whenever it's available we always have a
mint
you know when people say next level this
is a next level fish sea bass playing
the bass this is what you're like on
real dates a treat oh yeah hmm hello
pork oK we've gotten to the part of the
meal and we're just going hard right
here in your mouth Oh any like my whole
hotdogs the length worth of this and
then lastly we're going to have 85 Wagyu
from Kagoshima Japan served with a Maris
Piper potato simply grill it over Dakota
and charcoal high heat burns very very
clean chef de cuisine
Tristan started working on an idea that
he had which was to confit the potatoes
whole hollow them out all the scrap to
get from the Wagyu we make Bordelaise
sauce fill it with a sauce and then we
deep fry the potato brush it with more
of that sauce and then garnished it with
little pickled red onions and chive and
that sort of thing the finest Wagyu can
buy for sure
what you do first eat the steak this
looks like a Minecraft block that good
like Lego that on top show you wag me Oh
[Music]
Oh
if cows lay two eggs there you go no
potatoes lay eggs the cow turn into a
soup dumpling it is like a soup dumpling
this is the best steak I've ever had
best potato I read
[Music]
well you guys probably want to talk to
Jesse about the desserts
I'm the pastry chef at Providence
restaurant the dessert today is a black
horse of nice so he has a chocolate cake
a cherry olive sauce elonka chramu
pickle cherry black olives cherry
whipped cream which is like cherry pit
infused cream dry all the crumbs and the
cherry ice cream chocolate shards
chocolate lace just give me some crunch
is it more pressure to be the last dish
of this amazing tasting menu yes it's
successful it's a cake you just put your
spoon in we saw it coming out
[Music]
oh so easy to put my in fYI eyelids are
my weakness I love all foods I was not
as much I loved all of the foods
Wow it's kind of like an adult cocktail
but happening inside of a chocolate cake
you can come up with a dish like this
I'll cherry ice cream
[Music]
pretty good right and if you tell
somebody oh I went prophets and I ate
fine-dining seafood it's like it can't
explain what we eat today the next time
I have an olive and a piece of chocolate
yes in some proximity to each other
gonna be totally different I don't want
to sound like I'm gushing but much like
the potato we had I have been filled
with something anew and I'm ready to
burst forth with it
[Music]
Oh
[Music]